Ever since Avengers: Infinity War ended, fans
have been speculating over just who is going
to actually be in 2019's Avengers 4.
Rumors are swirling that the film will feature
pretty much every character in the entire
Marvel Cinematic Universe, with stars revealing
they filmed one scene that included nearly
three dozen heroes.
"I think in one particular scene there's like
32..
There's a lot of us There's so many of us!"
But it turns out some of your favorites still
won't join the party.
Why?
Here's a look at some Marvel characters who
will not be in Avengers 4.
Adam Warlock
Avengers 4 co-director Joe Russo dashed the
hopes of some fans when he made it clear Adam
Warlock would not be appearing in Avengers
4.
Warlock was a pivotal figure in the 1991 comic
book miniseries Infinity Gauntlet from which
Avengers: Infinity War takes much of its inspiration.
One of Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2's mid-credits
scenes fed fans' expectations that Warlock
would appear in either Infinity War or its
sequel.
"I think I shall call him…
Adam"
Regardless, Russo told ComicBook.com it isn't
happening.
"I have no interest as a director in telling
a story that's already been told or in seeing
one that's already been told.
If I know all the events […] as they're
going to happen, then what's the point of
going to the film?"
Plus, with director James Gunn no longer running
the Guardians of the Galaxy franchise, there's
no telling now whether Warlock will ever show
up at all.
Bummer.
The X-Men and the Fantastic Four
In spite of rumors to the contrary, Marvel
Studios president Kevin Feige insists that
neither the X-Men nor the Fantastic Four will
appear in Avengers 4 even if Disney's planned
acquisition of Fox goes through as planned,
partly because Avengers 4 has already been
filmed, and the editing process has already
begun.
Feige told the Daily News that when it comes
to the X-Men and the Fantastic Four potentially
joining the MCU,
"I have vague dreams and vague ideas.
But right now, bringing to life the 10,000-plus
characters that Marvel fully controls is what
the gameplan is."
Marvel's Netflix heroes
If you're hoping to see the cast of Netflix's
Defenders or Punisher in Avengers 4, you should
probably go ahead and feel the disappointment
now.
In March 2018, Joe Russo told Premiere the
Netflix heroes were considered for inclusion
in Avengers: Infinity War, but it would've
been too much to juggle, especially with so
many different directors involved.
"[T]he trick is that we already have at least
sixty characters with whom we must tell a
story!
And it's hard enough to communicate with Taika
Waititi, Ryan Coogler, Scott Derrickson, Peyton
Reed and James Gunn at the same time, not
to add all the showrunners and TV crews to
this … So it's practically impossible.
Our job is to focus on the Marvel film world
and offer a satisfying climax."'
Of course, in the interview Russo was talking
specifically about Infinity War, not Avengers
4, but it's safe to assume it applies to Avengers
4 as well.
"Oh my god, this is the dumbest"
Silver Surfer
Before the release of Avengers: Infinity War,
rumors flew around the web that Silver Surfer
would make a surprise appearance in the film.
Spoilers: he didn't.
And while the rumor mill is just getting started
when it comes to Avengers 4, you probably
shouldn't believe any reports you hear about
Silver Surfer making a cameo in it.
Like the X-Men and the Fantastic Four, the
rights to Silver Surfer are held up in the
Disney-Fox acquisition.
Even if that gets resolved before Avengers
4 comes out, expect Silver Surfer to make
his debut later rather than sooner.
Deadpool
As soon as Disney's attempt to acquire Fox
was announced, Deadpool star Ryan Reynolds
trolled the Mouse House by re-tweeting a picture
of Deadpool being escorted out of Disneyland.
Later, after the success of Avengers: Infinity
War, Reynolds tweeted congratulations to the
team by posting what he said was his Avengers
rejection letter from Tony Stark.
Hey, given what happened to his last team,
can you really blame them?
"but there is a slight chance that Vanisher
could make it…
Nope... no chance, he's dead."
But while fans have pushed all sorts of theories
about how and why Deadpool may make a surprise
appearance in Avengers 4, it seems very unlikely
given Deadpool faces the same rights challenges
as the X-Men, Fantastic Four, and Silver Surfer.
For the time being, he'll just have to do
as the Avengers rejection letter suggested
and stick with bothering Professor X.
"how about those pots with the giant pigeon
wings?
What do those do anyway?
Carry him three feet off the ground to pick
up the nearest muffin crumb?"